la unión europea cree que aún es posible
poder cerrar un acuerdo comercial con
reino unido- antes de que finalice el
mes pero insiste en que no a cualquier
precio por ello pide a londres
movimientos suficientes hoy terminaba la
fecha límite que había impuesto boris
johnson para cerrar un acuerdo comercial
pero aunque ha habido avances estos no
han sido suficientes porque aún hay
importantes escollos como por ejemplo la
cuestión de la pesca un tema que importa
mucho a países como españa o francia
pero para reino unido- es un tema muy
sensible porque no quiere un acceso
total a sus aguas territoriales por otra
parte está la cuestión de que la unión
europea pide a reino unido- que
realmente se comprometa que no se vaya a
convertir una especie de paraíso fiscal
a las puertas de europa y por último la
creación de un tribunal de arbitraje en
caso de que sea necesario si hay una
disputa comercial entre ambos bloques
aunque parecen temas menores no lo son
pero fuentes diplomáticas aseguran que
tampoco son cuestiones insalvables por
ello la unión europea confía en que las
dos próximas semanas de negociaciones
sea
clave para poder cerrar un pacto ahora
la pelota está en el tejado de londres
pero al gobierno británico no le ha
sentado nada bien el mensaje que han
enviado hoy los líderes europeos